from Disclose TV let me just make sure
the audio is configured properly which
is not and then we'll play this video
for you
thank you Mr President Mr President
okay let me try that again thank you so
look at it over here look at this thank
you oh oh no where's he gone
[Applause]
away
it looks like an episode of The Office
yes yeah it does man you really could
this really could be a sitcom it's kind
of like Veep or something well
somebody's got to make fun of it
sometime soon in a in a formal way but
look here I have a legitimate question
see his hands look at this look look at
that oh yeah you probably hit this out
earlier this is great see his hands
I I remember you know when I'm a kid Mr
Burns he walks around with his hands
like this
and I thought it was just like that's Mr
Burns it's something funny you see Joe
Biden doing this I'm like is that
something that people actually do when
they get old maybe it's like a balance
issue because if their arms are swinging
at the sides you lose balance easier
maybe and so they keep them nice and
tight to the chest I've seen this in old
people yes it's so weird right I never
thought about it until just now but they
definitely walk like a little well maybe
they could catch themselves
I'm a Mr President thought he was about
to topple well and remember remember he
fell trying to grab the dog's tail right
you hurt himself
he maybe learned his lesson you know
he's gotta be really careful yeah I
don't know man but uh to get serious I
would just like to apologize for the
joke opening the segment because no we
are not going to rest easy with this
President you know look man when I wake
up to the news that NATO was like yeah
that was sabotage and we will destroy
our enemies well they didn't say it like
that but you know they said they'll
collectively retaliate I'm like this is
a major historical moment where the NATO
military Alliance says formally that we
will enter the war against you and like
we know what that means and I'm just
like and Joe Biden is the president and
I'm thinking of videos like this there's
the video where remember when he was
like doing the Cornholio thing on CNN
there's all the gibberish words and you
know for a while the media kept trying
to act like he was fine and these left
activists and these Democrat activists
were alike he's totally sharp he's
totally with it it's Trump who's crazy
and they can't anymore now we have the
funny thing is not only is Joe Biden's
brain not working but the reporters try
talking to Karine Jean-Pierre and she
just says a bunch of random words and
now it's like at a certain point I think
regular people and these journalists are
kind of like
I don't think anybody's at work right
like I don't it's like imagine you go to
a an Applebee's and you walk in and
there's just like nobody and you're like
hey what's going on they're like sup and
you're like I'm hungry and like cool
it's good are you open no okay you'd
leave right but this is the government
this is our country at a time of an
escalating towards war with potentially
China with Russia an economic collapse
but you know what
you know what I can probably maybe I'm
putting the cart before the horse here
maybe the issue is the reason we're
close to war with Russia and China and
there's an economic collapse is because
this man is our president yes and it's
not it could have been a lot of
different people that would have gotten
us here but he's one of them and it's
because his kids and working in barisma
in Ukraine it's some Energy company he
was heavily involved with Obama during
the coup in 2014 in Ukraine that where
they tried to get the Ukraine to go side
with America and the liberal economic
order instead of Russia very explicitly
this is old Colbert uh this is a great
this came up on the Dave Smith Joe Rogan
episode again and I don't have the guy's
name uh this old you know I'm gonna look
into this and pull up the name in a
little bit but they've been planning
this for like two decades at the very
least at the very least and Biden has
been involved in it since the beginning
or at least since the Obama
Administration and there's too much for
him to lose if it gets found out how
much he's been involved putting his son
on the board of an energy company
to get to get there then to switch sides
in the the information is out there the
information is out there and it's there
for playing I just can't imagine my my
father and my grandfather allowing this
that's that's what's really ticking me
off about this really we're allowing
this to happen we're allowing this
bumbling you know systemic problem
throughout the the upper echelons of our
government and we just look at it it's
like yeah you know why not ultimately
we're the ones that are supposed to hold
these people accountable and I see none
of that from the media or not none but
not near as much as you should have and
why are we allowing this let me give you
one of my favorite Wikipedia articles of
all time it is the Biden Ukraine
conspiracy theory article let me read
for you this opening line the Biden
Ukraine conspiracy theory is a series of
false claims centered on the baseless
allegations oh they said false animates
that while Joe Biden was vice president
the US he engaged in corrupt activities
relating to the employment of his son
Hunter Biden by the Ukrainian Gas
Company barisma they were spread
primarily in attempts to damage Joe
Biden's reputation during the 2020
presidential campaign U.S intelligence
Community analysis released in March
2021 found the proxies of Russian
intelligence promoted and laundered
misleading and unsubstantiated
narratives about the bidens to U.S media
organizations U.S officials and
prominent U.S individuals including some
close to the former president from
president Trump and his administration
now over here on the right is a picture
it says Victor shoken one of the primary
subjects of the conspiracy theory the
conspiracy theory alleges that then Vice
President Joe Biden withheld loan
guarantees to pressure Ukraine into
firing shoken to prevent a corruption
investigation into barisma and to
protect his son Hunter Biden let's slow
down real quick and break down what's
wrong with this paragraph we'll go step
by step Victor shoken prosecutor he
exists he is in fact subject of the
story all right next sentence it alleges
then Vice President Joe Biden withheld
loan guarantees
he did on video bragging about how he
did next
they say to pressure Ukraine into firing
shoken he did it's on video him saying
so SOB guy gets fired they say to
prevent a corruption investigation into
barisma full stop
it did the firing of Victor shoken which
Joe Biden bragged about did result in
the ending of I think 12 active
investigations check Matt taibi's
reporting on this we we all know what's
happening now this question of did Joe
Biden pressure Ukraine into firing
Victor shulkin yes he did but did he do
it specifically to stop this corruption
investigation that we don't know but it
did stop the corruption investigation
how about that they called it a
conspiracy theory by injecting one
percent into the story intent what we
know is Biden did threatened to withhold
illegally I might add loan guarantees
did get the prosecutor fired the fire of
the prosecutor did result in an end to
investigations into barisma and that did
have the added effect of protecting
Hunter Biden now I call that plain and
simple a conflict of interest that alone
warrants in my opinion some kind of
inquiry investigation or hearing to get
to the bottom of how that happened
because there is a question of the
intent but you know what I don't know
his intent to call that whole thing a
conspiracy theory what you're actually
saying to me is it's probably true and
you're terrified that we found out what
would happen if it was Donald Trump and
his sons doing business well
yeah I'm triggered Loop go ahead Donald
Trump sees the video on Twitter of Joe
Biden being like let's hope he got fired
and so Donald Trump's on the phone with
the president of Ukraine like what is
this video I mean read the transcript's
hilarious he's like what's this video
about withholding Gary why don't you
look into this and they impeached him
over it yeah he accidentally discovered
a quid pro quo so they blamed him for
the quid pro quo and then claimed he was
trying to dig up dirt on his president
on his political rival even though Joe
Biden wasn't running for office at the
time and that's a preemptive narrative I
mean it's a preemptive narrative it's
accusing your enemy of what it is that
you were doing and and they use that
just to keep just to keep themselves out
of out of the line Because by the time
you get back to them by the time you
figure out yeah you were you were the
ones actually doing what you accused all
of it it's like my my father used to say
this it's a really good analogy you know
if you burn your hand on an iron it
hurts really really bad the first time
but if you do it 50 times eventually you
can't feel it anymore true you know and
that's and that's that's exactly what
they do with this stuff and they do it
to protect corrupt people and it's it's
plainly visible I just wish that we
could you know get some of the feeling
back in our callous uh Minds on the
subjects and and do something about it I
got the name this guy's name is oh you
got to grab your microphone Gideon rose
on Stephen Colbert Report back in the
day there's a video of Gideon rose on
the Colbert reports talking about the
plan to get Ukraine away from Russia and
take it to the United States it's like
in 2008 2009 and it is so overt he's
blatantly like yes think of it as like
they're the robin to to Russia's Batman
and we got to get Robin to be on our
side and not on Batman's side so he's
basically saying we're the Joker yeah
good call I guess we're the Scarecrow
unless you want to argue like we're
Green Lantern or no we're we're Green
Arrow and we want Robin to join us and
be our new Speedy but also just to come
back to the original topic of this story
I I think Joe Biden is definitely
putting his hand in the cookie jar he's
definitely profiting off of this but I
don't think he's calling the shots here
I think this has been going on way
before Biden became president of the
United States I think there are shadowy
powers behind the scenes instituting a
lot of these plans and I don't think
Biden's in charge he made a steep he
made a statement in Poland a couple of
months ago saying Putin could can't stay
in power the White House had to walk it
back and said and said he didn't mean
what he said he said recently we're
going to defend Taiwan the White House
had to make a statement saying no we
don't actually stand by that whatever
Biden says the White House corrects him
on who's correcting him who's making
sure that the policies of the United
States are not the policies of the
commander-in-chief there is something
else behind the scenes organizing
orchestrating a lot of this and him
being senile him being old I think it's
all a show it's all a play so he could
be the Fall Guy for the larger agenda
that's being shoved down everyone's
throat but why did Obama make him why
did Obama put Ukraine in his portfolio
though you know
because he was known well did he have
those connections before he was vice
president or did he make those
connections because he was well he was
also on a senate intelligence committee
he was also a longtime Senator so he had
his hands in a lot of foreign policy in
a lot of contracts in a lot of business
dealings between China and all these
other Kazakhstan countries all
throughout the world so so he was a man
who of course had intelligence
connections and had his hands everywhere
but it looks like barisma was very
pro-russia before the Ukraine flipped in
2014 and so the way for barisma to be
like hey America we want to be on your
side they were like we'll just take like
our Point man their point man was Biden
he was the guy we'll just take his son
on our board and that way we'll make
sure we're on the up and up we'll we'll
profit wasn't there a former CIA
director yeah and a CIA guy was on there
too yeah on prisma's board yeah that was
their way of of snuggling up to the to
the United States After the Revolution
you can call it
um Luke I think you're right that
Biden's not calling the shots like we
think he is or that a lot of people
think is and Trump wasn't either he
would he tried to get the troops out of
the Middle East I think out of Syria
particularly and they do what they call
Shell games where the military is like
yeah we have they were lying to him
about the numbers of troops so he's like
okay then I guess we've reached our
number of withdrawals they're like yeah
yeah that's right that's right and they
weren't doing what they were told well
okay it was a former director of
counter-terror Joseph Cofer black who
was uh I believe he was on the board he
was yes he was on the board so I I I
think he's the CIA guy I don't think it
was uh direct or anything well and going
back to your point of the uh oh he was
director of counter system specifically
so going back to your point of Biden
being kind of the the shell guy you know
I just keep going back in my mind to
that to Obama saying you know if I could
just have a third term where I wasn't
taking all the the arrows and I could
just put somebody up there do all the
you know take all the the crap that I
got for all these years and just make
the decisions behind the scenes that's
what I would really like to do I just
keep going back to that and it makes
very it makes a lot of sense yeah but
Obama wasn't that big of a Warhawk when
it came to Ukraine he was he was afraid
to send lethal weapons to you but was
that because he didn't want to be or is
it because he couldn't be
um that's a good question I don't know
I'm not in his mind but but we know he
was very soft uh on Ukraine
comparatively to a lot of the other new
neoconservative hawkish policies that
were pushed on by previous and
predecessor administrations that were
more heavy-handed and escalated tensions
even more than he did but but he even
when he came out of office said I I
regret being so uh hawkish he he
regretted the drone strikes so so again
I'm not trying to give him any favors I
thought he was a horrible president just
like every president just like every
politician because I don't trust any
government I don't trust any politicians
and I think naturally people shouldn't
be trusting anyone in our political
landscape right now all of these people
do not deserve your trust do not deserve
your attention do not deserve your
energy if enough of us would would see
politics like this I don't think we
would be in this mess right now because
we wouldn't be giving them all of our
power all of our money all of our
authority to do this nonsense that
they're doing right now thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to Tim cast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there